jordan peterson i really don't know much
about this guy before we get into it
make sure to like subscribe yeah do your
things we're getting a bunch of views of
video and we're live
and hit us up on rumble tube because
youtube has been taking down our videos
hit us on a rumble that's all let's go
come on do you have any comments on the
nazi presence at your protest
the presence of nazis and white
supremacists assaulting people at your
protest do you have any comments on that
yeah i don't like nazis well no [ __ ]
[ __ ] so you got somebody going are there
nazis here really we're the nazis even
if there are a few crazy they come after
trump with that [ __ ] too i mean you
can't define an entire population of
people
by a few fringe lunatics are you going
to not fail are you going to go after
big social media companies because they
have bad people on there on their
platforms what do you feel about nazi
having a twitter account like that makes
no sense medicine that he would refer to
me as a um as she and wouldn't have a
problem with that
um but at the end of the day you know
personal pronoun preference still is a
preference
for what language other people use
and at the end of the day i don't uh
have ultimate control of over what dr
peterson uh what the language he chooses
to use or anybody else for that matter
that's that's up to them okay let me
find out that arises let me find out if
she were a student of yours what would
you call her
she you would okay
we've established that why should your
right to freedom of speech
trump a trans person's right not to be
offended you're right to not be offended
there's no such thing as a right to not
be offended what what is what is this
new [ __ ] where no one can get offended
anymore right this is why you're right
to be offended you could be offended all
[ __ ] day nobody cares though i don't
have to give a [ __ ] about you being
offended do i no you don't and that's
why people are so soft and can't get
anything done because they're they're
cuddled since they're little to not to
not get offended or anything they have
bulldozer parents that do everything for
them these people are not prepared for
the real world you need struggle you
need to fight you do you do we should be
polite to each other and do our best to
not offend but you know what that
doesn't mean i'm gonna tiptoe and
pretend i believe [ __ ] that i don't
because of your feelings sorry and you
shouldn't have to do the same to me i
also want you to speak your mind and
your convictions to me and if i choose
to be offended that is my [ __ ] that is
my emotions i can either control them or
not because in order to be able to think
you have to risk being offensive i mean
look at the conversation we're having
right now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
say is it even better than rather
uncomfortable
well i'm very glad i put
destroyed her and i'm glad he did what
about cause she's she's in there being a
smug [ __ ] smug [ __ ]
what about what about my feelings
what gives you the right to talk really
and not worry about my right to be
offended as a white male your feelings
don't matter white devil not that is
what you should do but you're exercising
your freedom of speech to certainly risk
offending me
and that's fine i think more power to
you as far as i'm concerned
except you haven't sat there and
i'm just trying i'm just trying to work
that out i mean
it's not that complicated gotcha you
have got me you have got me i'm trying
to yeah chris it's [ __ ] simple and
true you think she's good things she's
pretty these people listen to argue they
don't even listen for conversation they
let they listen to like well how can i
get them back yeah they don't listen to
learn
my head and there's not a secular
humanist organization or country on the
planet that has ever produced as a good
thing an intentional good thing rapists
and murderers so well that's dip that's
highly debatable well what did he say
that's highly debatable actually one of
the things absolutely true because
there's never been a secular humanist
government on the planet
i don't know i think the soviets were
pretty sick
you do not know the first thing about
what secular humanism is you should read
the secular humanist manifestos can you
explain that to me i'm not too familiar
with it i'm going to google because i am
never going to explain that anywhere in
our secular humanism humanism with
regard in particular to the belief that
humanity is capable of morality and
self-fulfillment without belief in god
oh that's okay so non you know so saying
that you can have more
without the belief in god
which i think is absolutely true
absolutely it's true i don't know an
atheist can believe that you know not to
be a um no yeah not to be a bottom
feeder not to be a a thief not to be a
womanizer or a cheat i mean absolutely
you do not need no no i know you i don't
know i know you don't have a good moral
fiber no i know i agree with you that
you don't need it but it is it is i i
don't know it's so weird because i just
believe in energy and stuff so much that
it's it's it's kind of weird to think
about if you just thought nothing was
meant to happen everything's kind of
just whatever my initial thinking was
that like these people that don't
believe in god i'm like how could you
how could you i just think it's a very
naive approach because there's so much
stuff that we don't understand and
there's it's naive i don't think it's
hard
i think maybe they just haven't
experienced those moments that i know i
have around god and those those not even
god
a greater power but a secular person can
understand those scientific things that
for example albert einstein began to
discover i'd like to go back to what the
man said about secular humanism earlier
at the beginning of this clip because i
think yeah right there because i think
we'll understand it better the second
time humanism is the is that you don't
believe you don't believe in god okay
that you can have strong morals without
believing in god and there's not a
secular humanist organization or country
on the planet that has ever produced as
a good thing an intentional good thing
rapists and murderers okay so there's
not okay so there's not a group that
doesn't believe in god that's ever
intentionally produced rapists and
murderers now the nazis you know they
they persecuted people of all religions
under hitler and they did think it was a
good thing to produce rapists and
murderers so what am i missing i mean i
i may just be not understanding because
these guys are clearly up to their necks
in this type of study these are these
are hyper intellectuals a lot of big
words i'm not that smart mom i'm a
marketer well let's get smarter that's
that's highly debatable
that's highly debatable actually one of
the things absolutely true because
there's never been a secular humanist
government on the planet
i don't know i think the soviets were
pretty sick
with all with all due apologies you do
not know the first thing about what
secular humanism is you should read the
secular humanist manifestos because what
happened in russia in communist
countries was an institution of a
religious-like structure surrounded
around centered around an individual and
forced atheism none of which is
consistent with humanism the great
american philosopher beyonce knows okay
said that it has been said that racism
is so american
that if you challenge racism
you look like you're challenging america
we are challenging inequality we are
challenging the refusal to see me as an
individual when we that is [ __ ] we
see you as an individual you are not
challenging inequality you're
challenging inequity that's what they're
doing we all have a quality of
opportunity they want equity of outcome
not everybody's going to get the same
outcome that the halfway who lives
around the corner that can't even get
out of bed and or get a job or hold a
job at [ __ ] subway is not the same as
the scientists he's not going to get the
same outcomes in life he has the same
opportunities same rights but he's not
going to get the same outcome so that's
[ __ ] because they take that word of
quality and they again screwed it the
way they screw up a lot of words
with billions of dollars so let's boo
hoo your side spoke so i'm gonna go
jordan then to you let's assume for a
moment that i've benefited from my white
privilege okay so let's assume that
that's fine okay let's assume that's
what you would say
so um um so let's say
here let's get precise about this okay
was that in the very individual of you
let's get precise about this okay
to what degree is my present level of
attainment or achievement
a consequence of my white privilege and
i don't mean sort of i mean do you mean
five percent do you mean 15
do you mean 25
do you mean 75 and what do you propose i
do about it how about a tax
how about a tax that's like specialized
for me so that i can account for my damn
privilege so that i created
[Applause]
get precise about one other thing bring
about it
account for my damn privilege so that i
created it right about it you're talking
great great [ __ ] right now let's tax
yeah let's tax that white's extra but
okay what did she say
let's just say there is white privilege
okay he's got jordan peterson's got
white privilege for the sake of the
conversation as he as he brought up is
that holding anyone else back is that
whole really holding anyone else back
and they'll say yeah because he he has
uh you know he he's ahead of the start
line or the finish line is closer for
him however you want to look at it even
if you got to take an extra couple steps
or it's a little harder you can still do
whatever he did it's not even as much
about race as it is where you came from
and it's also they don't even
acknowledge that there's like yes
there's some white privileges like yes
black people are definitely like more
likely to get pulled over by police and
stuff and that's that's wrong and we
have a great black we all agree on that
if you're black you could come from the
same neighborhood as a white kid have
all the same qualifications but get into
that college because of because of your
race that's a privilege too but i can't
say that and i can't say that because
i'm white that's a privilege that i
don't have is i'm not able to speak my
mind as much or else i'm getting called
names because of the color of my skin
you know what i mean how they made this
whole country and every single thing we
do about race when we were so far ahead
of this it's droid [ __ ] it's it's
royalty [ __ ] it's me it is proof of the
matrix and just people we were so far
ahead of this as a society and they've
drawn us down to fighting over skin
color are you [ __ ] kidding me it's
broken [ __ ] it is literally droid broken
[ __ ] you think when i'm hiring someone
for my companies that i look at at the
color of their skin i don't even look if
you went to college i look at the work
that you sent me that you've previously
done it's just so crazy that like we're
talking about your work your ability
your attitude like if you're a good fit
and you just gotta work ethic that's all
that matters idiotic don't buy this [ __ ]
one other thing okay we'll get precise
about one other thing
precise yeah precise
yes and so
if
if we can agree and we haven't that the
left can go too far which it clearly
can't then how would my worthy opponents
precisely define when the left that they
stand for has gone too far you didn't
like equity equality of outcome i think
that's a great marker but if you have a
better suggestion and and won't sidestep
the question so let's figure out how i
can dispense with my white privilege and
so that you can tell me when the left
has gone too far since they clearly can
and that's what this debate is about
they can't be correct there is no it's
about the
and i think it's gone too far in many
ways and i'd like to figure out exactly
how and when so the reasonable left
could make its ascendance again and we
could quit all this nonsense when you
talk about this dude
then it almost sounds derogatory it's
almost as if you're saying that to be
feminine or to express any sort of
femininity is actually inferior to
masculinity um and i think that is a
huge problem even with within the
language that we use you know when you
say don't be such a girl don't be such a
[ __ ] the the greatest insults that men
can give each other tend to have
feminine or origins like you know as i
said [ __ ] or [ __ ] um or anything like
that and i think again that speaks to um
a very systematic um inequality between
the judges shut up um and you attributed
the the the rates of mental illness
among men to their inability to express
say sentimental emotions so i don't
think there's a shred of clinical
evidence to support that stance
sorry um
well i don't think there's a shred of
evidence i mean that stance the kind of
violence for example that lawrence is
discussing is a consequence of
competitive it's part of it really
matters competitive violence
i think there is some evidence that men
find it difficult to talk about things
and that that um
ways in which you can help young men to
talk about things
the evidence for the differential rates
of mental health
i also don't think i um when you're
talking about things being so innate um
you know i mean judith butler would have
said that you know gender is a construct
that gender is a performance well judith
butler doesn't know what she's talking
about in the least so i don't accept i
mean that's interesting but i i she's
not a scientist she doesn't know this
but then if you look at someone like
this is all under the influence you say
of post-modernism and
neo-marxism yeah but well aren't those
things two separate things they're
completely separate you know and this is
something i've been criticized for dr
peterson doesn't understand the
difference between neo-marxism and pl
and and post-modernism it's like i
understand the difference perfectly well
it isn't me that's conflating them it
turns out that the people who push
post-modern doctrines in the university
almost always ally themselves with a
marxist viewpoint and
that is
logically incoherent but i would say the
post-modernists don't give a damn for
logical coherence because they regard
that as part of the oppressive
patriarchal eurocentric view of the
world yes logic is part of the
patriarchy okay explain that to me like
i'm a fifth grader because i totally
just understood every single thing that
they just said it's basically saying
that logic that progressivism is
illogical and they justify it by saying
that logic is okay so basically it's
part of the patriarch patriarchy what i
heard is that like they're continuously
saying that the old logic and and
everything that is known to me to be
true is actually not true and that we
need to just continue with this new
modern [ __ ] is that basically what he
was saying yeah you did better job than
me okay that's that's kind of what i
took out of it but using a lot of big
words dude idea that there's an
objective reality in all of that if you
can deal with
logic you accept this oppression
narrative without question you know 102
i don't i don't accept anything without
question i'm just telling you a fact
that's not a fact yes it is no it's not
women women were expected to stay home
and take care of the kids and cook a
meal that's a women didn't have a
reliable birth control until 1960 you
know don't you think that played a role
don't you think the fact that they they
didn't have reliable care are you
blaming women for not being allowed to
lead countries to lead nations because
they were allowed to lead nations there
were queens in many countries i think
you have no idea how much that's what's
your [ __ ] complaint saturated you're
thinking why do you think it is that so
much of what you
say
is so very popular with the alt-right it
isn't and you don't have any evidence
for that at all well any more than the
evidence that alt-right people neonate
websites
in civilization oh well there was that
was all taken apart today by a number of
jewish publications by the way showing
that first of all that was all satirical
commentary on the part of the alt-right
directed at taking me down for example
and there was an alt-right article
yesterday published
saying that i was a jewish stooge and
shill so this is absolute nonsense and i
don't uh i don't appeal primarily to the
alt-right there's no evidence i love
that this man is intelligent and just
keeps his emotions out of things enough
to know when there's satirical comment
on him commentary on him satire satire
it's a joke it's intelligent humor
whether you like it or not he can look
at that and see that it's satire and see
that it's hyperbole and just carry on
with his day i never said primarily um
jordan what i'm interested in is why you
think that you get the reaction that you
do from the alt-right looking at you
know the kathy newman documentary
into interview there was 10 million
people watching comments i'm talking
about what i saw
and i'm curious to know what your
reaction was to the to the to the glee
with which the alt-right seized upon
that i don't accept what you do with the
death threats i mean i think it was
accepted the concept that it was the
alt-right that was doing this there were
10 million people who commented on that
video and about 95 of them commented
negatively on kathy newman's behavior
you think there's 10 million alt-right
trolls watching that
of the pursuit of justice characterizing
the modern university i see a tremendous
amount of the pursuit of vengeance
even if like who cares why is his
audience like
how like reacting to it have anything to
do with him the all right words to you
what's what's your reaction to them
liking what you say how can they like it
who gives it what are you asking me for
go ask them things that don't even
deserve to have vengeance extracted for
them so give me an example of what
doesn't deserve vengeance how about the
existence of the patriarchy
you but you don't mean now that women
have not suffered injustices in britain
virginia woolf couldn't go to university
or rather she couldn't that's not what
he's saying women have been that's not
what he said he said just enough let it
go it's in the past he said it doesn't
need punishing because it's over
virginia wolf dude is so smart come here
come here wait no sorry everybody i just
wanna just for the sake of proving how
ridiculous it is virginia woolf a you
know very celebrated author who i
thought was dead boring but you know not
my bag okay she was born in 1882 and
died in 1941 oh my god we're using her
as an example of a woman that couldn't
go to university
as his argument that's what he's using
yet still she is still one of the most
celebrated famous woman of all time so
movies made about her they carry on her
book still sell i mean she's still
studied in every [ __ ] high school and
university in america and he's going to
complain that she had it rough come on
quit it philip dodd anything that's
proof that you can overcome oppression
even though that they actually were more
oppressed oppressed back then yeah than
the fake oppression that they push on
people now that you can overcome you can
overcome and do whatever you want gee
you can do whatever you want right he
can how could he not see you no but
you're oppressed and they want you to
stay oppressed and sad that you're
oppressed and there's nothing i can do
well 450 years ago couldn't go to school
oh my god [ __ ] up man i'm sorry excluded
in all kinds of ways from social
situations have they not yes but people
have been excluded from social
situations in all kinds of ways and i
don't like this the narrative the the
social historical injustice narrative as
a way of looking at the world the way
that that young people now are taught
about the relationships between men and
women throughout history is that the
fundamental narrative is that men
oppressed women throughout the course of
history and then that kind of came to an
end when everybody woke up in 1974 yeah
really
no listen
i don't know what it's like in canadian
universities but that's what i call that
forgive this european reference that's a
kind of punch and duty way of seeing it
that is not how universities as a whole
operate well that's how they operate in
canada we had the biggest scandal in
canadian university history last year
when a graduate student was hauled in
front of a maoist inquisition for daring
to show a five-minute video of me
discussing issues like this on public
television the universities are in far
worse shape maybe they're not in such
bad shape in the uk as they are in in
north america but they're in plenty bad
shape in north very bad shape for north
america and i'm sorry horrible but that
is not the biggest scandal the biggest
scandal will be the number for instance
of suicides that are prevalent amongst
the undergraduates the fact that one
academic was holed up in my view
inappropriately for doing what was done
is not the biggest scandal you're
inflating it's not that's a horrible
thing that's a tragedy that we have so
many suicides but that cannot be
attributed to the patriarchy how do you
even make that make that leap this is
where i really lose faith in all of
these arguments there are a thousand
different reasons that a suicide could
take place and to assume that it's you
know the patriarchy and all this old
[ __ ] that happened a thousand years ago
is is responsible is not only
irresponsible it's gross and it's a
gross manipulation of truth
your background
it's pretty earthy
but how did you connect that with your
current political perspective what you
said that you became disillusioned with
socialism i became disillusioned with
ideology ideology in general yeah
definitely i mean that's certainly not
something that's changed i mean i don't
like ideologues
well first of all
you know whatever all right that was
pretty cool yeah i think we should
definitely react to more jordan peterson
that dude he's just so smart he's so
intelligent he's g he's definitely g i
want to watch this one can we just do
this right now no you got to stop doing
this it's getting annoying you have to
stop telling me to react to stuff after
we have to do it i'll tell you i asked
yeah do you want to do boxing i quit
mom quits give him a rating first no i'm
not giving anybody a reading i quit
you're mean to me people what do you
give them one to ten give them
[Music]
won't last long